so we're given these three rational
functions and we want to find you know
the equation of the horizontal asymptote
okay
and what we want to do is we want to
consider these three cases here you want
to look at the highest powered term in
the numerator and the highest powered
term in the denominator so that's the
one with a highest exponent and what you
do is you look and you say well if the
exponents are the same meaning in the M
equals n in this example here then the
horizontal asymptote is going to be the
ratio of those two coefficients that's
going to be a divided by B but see that
this exponent in the numerator is
smaller than the one in the denominator
or you could say the one in the
denominator is greater than the one in
the numerator either way then the
horizontal asymptote is going to be y
equals zero it can be right at the x
axis and the third scenario is when M is
greater than n meaning the numerators
exponent is higher than the denominators
exponent then we have no horizontal
asymptote or if it's just one degree
larger than the denominator then it's a
slant asymptote okay
so I'll show you a three examples so the
first one here what do you think well
you can see these are both X to the
first okay so it's a tie so what that
means is we end up with the ratio of the
coefficients which is y equals two
fourths which reduces to 1/2 so your
horizontal asymptote would look
something like that for number two you
can see that the denominators degree is
two the numerators degree is only one
the denominators degree is higher so our
horizontal asymptote is going to be y
equals zero that's going to be right at
the x-axis okay
and then the third one you can see that
the highest degree term here x squared
compared to the highest degree term the
denominator 2 acts this is a 2 for an
exponent that's only a 1 here you can
see that because this is larger in the
numerator by one degree you're actually
going to have a slant asymptote and in
order to find that slant asymptote what
you would do is you would do long
division polynomial long division to
find the equation that slant asymptote
if you want to find out more about
graphing how to actually graph these
entire rational functions follow me over
to that video right there and we'll
discuss how to do all the different
aspects of graphing rational functions
I'll see you over in that video